[Music]
morning all us officials have warned
that russian forces have now moved about
three miles closer to the ukrainian
capital kiev over the last 24 hours new
satellite images suggest that troops
have reorganized to the north-west of
kiev in an area where a 40-mile long
convoy had been stalled for days while
the pictures show armored units moving
through times and repositioning in
forest with some artillery already in
firing positions
there are also reports this morning that
at least one person has been killed in
air strikes in the central city of
dimitro all this
as both the white house and boris
johnson warned that president putin
could soon turn to chemical weapons well
let's take a quick look at the key
developments and the uk's minister of
defense says it is highly unlikely that
russia has successfully achieved the
objectives it outlined in its
pre-invasion plan
the u.s defense source says that russia
has made well moderate advances towards
kiev in the past day forces have moved
three miles closer to the capital and
are now just 10 from the city centre
boris johnson has told sky news he
thinks that vladimir putin may be
preparing to use chemical weapons in
ukraine
and the g7 countries and the eu will
reportedly move today to strip russia of
its most favored nation trade status
which would allow them to impose tariffs
on russian goods skies sally lockwood
has our first report
for days a 40-mile military convoy had
stalled outside kiev
but images taken in the last 24 hours
suggest russian troops have reorganized
u.s satellite company maxam says
vehicles appear to have dispersed and
redeployed
with towed artillery now in firing
positions nearby
it comes as a senior u.s defense
official said russian troops have
advanced on the capital while the
information war escalates over whether a
chemical weapons attack is being planned
no chemical or any other weapons of mass
destruction were developed on my land
the whole world knows that
you know that
and if you do something like that
against us you will get the most severe
sanctions response
the scenes of a bombed maternity
hospital in mariopol suggest there are
no boundaries to russia's barbarism
the concern now is a chemical attack
russia has called a meeting of the u.n
security council later to discuss
unsubstantiated claims ukraine is
housing biological weapons
but the u.s has warned this is a ploy by
russia to create a pretext to deploy
such weapons itself
with no desire for nato military
involvement it seems the west's warnings
about red lines fall largely on deaf
ears in moscow
there is strong evidence that we are
seeing
war crimes taking place and we need to
take that evidence and record that
evidence we are working
to
collate the evidence on the ground of
what is happening to make sure that
putin
and his associates are held to account
for these appalling actions
the question is how to stop this now
ukrainians grieving their loved ones and
life as they knew it
police sergeant roman rashishan buried
by his wife and three young children to
the sound of defiant song
[Music]
but in some of the worst bombed areas
there's no dignity of a funeral and no
way to escape this fighting
sally lockwood sky news
well meanwhile the prime minister has
told sky news he thinks that russia's
vladimir putin may be preparing to use
chemical weapons in ukraine here's the
pm discussing that with our political
editor beth rigby
lavrov said concerns over civilian
casualties were to quote him pathetic
shrieks you know but i'm afraid that is
just where they are and you
and that is what we're dealing with and
i'll i'll make you one other prediction
by the way which is that the stuff that
you're hearing about
uh
chemical weapons this is straight out of
their playbook they start saying that
there are chemical weapons that have
been stored by uh their opponents or by
the americans and so when they
themselves deploy uh chemical weapons as
i as i fear they they may they have us a
sort of a massacre of a fake story ready
to go you can't see a way out at the
moment i can't see a way out that
doesn't begin with the realization uh by
the uh the kremlin that they made a
catastrophic mistake
i think that vladimir putin has himself
made it very difficult
to
find an off-ramp and he has i think
driven his uh his tanks so to speak down
a cul-de-sac from which it would be very
hard to extricate himself
i'm very pleased to say that the digital
economy minister chris philp joins us in
the studio as well at minister great to
have you in um
let's start with that which we are
hearing um beth discussing with the pm
there the the risk of chemical weapons
being brought in just to be very clear
about this
does the uk or or our allies allies have
specific intelligence that vladimir
putin is preparing to use chemical
weapons or are we extrapolating this
simply from what he has been saying
well clearly i can't comment on
intelligence the uk government may have
may have received that wouldn't be right
to speak about that publicly but we have
seen
in the last 24 or 48 hours what appear
to be
bits of disinformation published by
russian state outlets including in fact
uh the russian
embassy here in london
putting on things like twitter
information that appear to be
creating a false narrative that the
ukrainians are considering uh using
chemical weapons which is clearly
ridiculous and totally untrue and
sometimes they do that in preparation
but i hope that is that is not what
they're contemplating the use of
chemical weapons again any uh theater of
war but certainly one where there are
lots of civilians totally unacceptable
what we've seen the russians doing in
the last two weeks
in ukraine is totally barbaric we saw
them in the last day or two you know
shelling and bombing hospitals across
ukraine
including a hospital which was uh where
where young mothers were or new mothers
were giving birth to children what they
have done is is totally barbaric which
is why the united kingdom is determined
as the prime minister was saying to do
everything we can to try and stop them
but but in essence if vladimir putin is
willing to bomb a maternity ward he's
willing to do pretty much anything
well i as i say um i'm not going to talk
about intelligence but you know using
chemical weapons in an area which has
lots of civilians would be a barbaric
thing to do and you know i would just
say to to vladimir putin and to the
russian regime you know not to cross
that line not to do that to civilian
populations
let's then talk about that what we heard
yesterday that that finally eventually
um roman abramovich has been has been
sanctioned i'm just wondering i think
many people are wondering this what what
has changed in in the week since the
prime minister accidentally you know you
know misspoke and said that abramovich
was sanctioned when he was and what have
we learned in the past seven days that
has allowed us to move to this position
well the united kingdom of course is a
country which respects the rule of law
we have to go through a proper process
to make sure that everything is done in
a way that's legally waterside people
like abramovic you know have expensive
lawyers and we want to make sure that we
don't get challenged so we've gone
through carefully and methodically
putting together a case that is
watertight and yesterday we acted
against not just abramovic but six other
oligarchs who control critical russian
companies like rossia bank like rosneft
like gazprom these are a people
oligarchs and companies who are integral
to the putin regime they're sustaining
him they're supporting him they're
enabling him and it's right that we act
against them as part of our set of
measures of course we've already
sanctioned over 300 russian individuals
and entities and those and we've worked
with uh other countries to exchange
russia from the swift system but you
have to that's having a big effect you
have to accept that that
that any oligarch but particularly
someone with the amount the deep pockets
of roman abramovich will have moved
assets out of the country in the days
you know from when it first became
mooted that he would be sanctioned you
have to accept that well i mean there
are there are some asset assets that are
hard to move like chelsea football club
that's not going anywhere and the house
uh as far as you know that hasn't been
sold uh and of course we've also uh done
asset freezes against a number of of big
russian banks we have we've frozen the
assets of about a quarter of a trillion
pounds worth of russian bank balance
sheet assets and those were frozen a
while ago and that is more by the way
than the european union it's more than
the united states so those assets have
been frozen for some time now well let's
talk specifically about chelsea first
and foremost you're not a fan are you
i'm a palace man okay fair enough fair
enough so apologies if a suitable buyer
for chelsea was found is the government
currently minded to allow that deal to
go through yeah so as the license
conditions are written today
the sale would not be allowed however if
a buyer emerged then it would be open to
that buyer or to the football club
to approach the government and ask for
the license conditions to be varied in a
way that allowed that sale to take place
so they they'd be they'd be able to
approach the government to make a
proposal
but to be clear
no proposal would be accepted which saw
the money the proceeds of any sale
ending up in uh in an unrestricted bank
account owned by abramovic he can't
benefit from the proceeds of any sale
let's talk a little bit then about about
the the ukrainian refugee crisis and and
clearly as a crisis estimates originally
were around about 2 million people may
well be leaving the country those look
to be doubled the british public is
going to be asked to take in in refugees
themselves just explain a little bit
more about that scheme well it's worth
just talking about the the full spectrum
of our response to the humanitarian
crisis and first of all we've donated
aid valued at over 400 million pounds to
help the humanitarian crisis on the
ukrainian border that's more than any
other country
in the world and that is the that is the
response that the ukrainian president
principally asked for and we've met that
we've done it more than any other
country
secondly there is a route for fam people
with family members extended family
members in the uk to come over here and
the home secretary announced just
yesterday that where people have family
here and have a ukrainian passport then
we're not going to require them to go
and have biometric checks done which was
a bit of a bottleneck
specifically on the opening of doors so
so thirdly in addition to that we're
going to be making announcements in the
very near future about a scheme for uk
local authorities and indeed uk families
to welcome ukrainian refugees we've
announced that principle and the details
of how that scheme works will be laid
out in the very near future
would you take anyone in to your home i
mean do we know of anyone in the cabinet
that has already suggested that they
might be willing to open their doors
well i think once the details are
published in the very near future
everybody will have a look at that and
see if their personal circumstances
allow them to and you know i'm sure the
british public will look at that and if
they're able to some people will be able
to and some won't they'll they'll make
their own their own decisions just just
before we let you go just closer to your
briefing in fact we've been hearing
overnight indeed yesterday
facebook
has made a temporary
exception as they're describing it to
those that have been affected by war in
essence allowing them on their platform
to call for violence against russia
something which facebook would not allow
in any other circumstances are you
entirely sanguine with that
well i haven't seen the details of that
announcement so i'm slightly reluctant
to comment on uh what is uh what what
that
proposal without having seen the details
what i do know is that the russian
government have been trying to block
various social media platforms
from operating in russia as part of
their disinformation campaign to try and
essentially trick the russian people
they're lying to the russian people
about what is happening because if the
russian people realize the full extent
of the atrocities being committed by
putin in their name they would be
extremely angry and that is why putin is
trying to hide that from his own
population i understand this is
developing but we haven't had a
statement from facebook's parent
organization meta they say these are
temporary measures designed to preserve
voice and expression for people who are
facing invasion as always we are
prohibiting calls for violence against
russians outside of the narrow context
of the current invasion it's a narrow
context but again i'm just wondering how
you feel about one of the big tech
giants in essence allowing people to
call for violence against russians in a
way which we would probably not be
allowed to do in the streets of the uk
well i think it sounds like they're
talking about specifically in ukraine
and obviously ukrainian the ukrainian
army and ukrainian citizens have every
right to defend their homeland to defend
their cities and their towns to defend
their hospitals
against this aggression by russia and to
be honest if somebody was attacking
croydon uh the place i represent if
somebody was bombing croydon university
hospital i tell you what i would be in
the streets defending my hospital i'd be
in the streets defending my town and my
neighbors as the ukrainians are quite
rightly doing chris great to have you in
the studio thanks for joining us okay
well let's take a quick look at the
morning's papers again one story in town
at the guardian leading with a report
from the city of mario paul it describes
conditions there as
medieval after shelling from russian
forces
chelsea fc's billionaire owner roman
abramovich as we've just been discussing
well he has now been sanctioned by the
government and told that he has blood on
his hands that's the story in the metro
similar headline in the eye it says that
abramovic is among oligarchs complicit
in vladimir putin's invasion of ukraine
meanwhile the mirror calls abramovic and
vladimir putin blood brothers
the son claims that chelsea football
club could go bust as a result
and the telegraph reports that the
british public will be asked to offer
their homes to tens of thousands of
ukrainian refugees
well let's just take a closer look at
how the situation in ukraine stands this
morning
president zielenski says that a hundred
thousand people have been evacuated from
besieged areas in just the past two days
uh yesterday those included issues and
areas in and around sumi
able around kiev itself evacuations also
took place in urban buca and hostimal
kev's mayor vitaly klitschko says that
about two million people that is half of
the capital's population although they
have left in recent weeks
airstrikes were reported overnight in
denipro and april emergency services say
at least one person was killed two other
attacks near airports in the west were
also reported
in kharkiv yesterday a russian shelling
hit a building housing an experimental
nuclear reactor the ukrainian official
said equipment there could release
radiation if damaged
meanwhile the un's nuclear watchdog says
it's now lost all communications with
chernobyl which is under russian control
in the south ukrainian authorities say
1300 civilians are now dead in mariopol
which continues to come under heavy
bombardment
and looking ahead to today russia's
defense ministry has said it will
observe a ceasefire and open five
humanitarian corridors to let civilians
flee kiev sumi kharkiv sherniv and maria
paul other ceasefires have of course
been broken by russian forces in recent
days
well the polish capital warsaw is close
to being overwhelmed by the number of
refugees arriving from ukraine uh let's
speak now to lisa holland joining us
from warsaw good to see you this morning
lisa just just give us a bit of an idea
i can have a first person account of
just how dire the refugee situation is
beginning to come in poland
morning neil well yes of course the
reality is that when you have millions
of refugees crossing over the border in
a very quick period of time they of
course have to go somewhere they're not
staying on the border
so they are heading to major cities now
the vast majority of the refugees have
arrived in poland which means that the
polish capital warsaw where i am this
morning uh is of course really at the
sharp end of all of those arrivals um
we've worked out that something like 15
of the previous population of warsaw has
now arrived again
in terms of the numbers of refugees so
where do they all go and we've been at
the central train station which is a
fairly frantic chaotic scene of humanity
people figuring out what to do where to
go they're tired hungry getting off
trains
so in the very emergency initial phase
you'll they'll be greeted by people
giving them water food
medicine supplies even a toothbrush and
then after that of course they are then
having to work out should they try to
stay in poland and in fact um one family
that we spoke to told us quite candidly
that number one they'd quite like to go
to the uk but they have no family ties
so as of this minute they're not
eligible um but also they can see around
them the pressure on the polish
authorities and they're saying look we
can see how busy it is here so we want
to move on to somewhere else such as
germany we saw a lot of people queuing
for a bus to germany but they didn't
even know what time it would go or even
what city they wanted to end up in and
one thing they do know though is that
they want to get away from ukraine but i
think what is significantly different
here compared to other previous
migration situations is that people
don't want to permanently get away from
ukraine of course the almost all the
people that we saw yesterday
were women and children so they have
left husbands relatives brothers fathers
back in ukraine and eventually they do
want to go back but right now there is
this emergency situation to provide them
people here in warsaw with beds with a
roof over their head and some kind of
shelter
food and just keep them going
whilst events continue on the ground in
ukraine
lisa many thanks
plenty more still to come on the show
in just under an hour i'll be speaking
to labour's shadow international trade
secretary thomas simmons
i'll also be speaking with the former
head of the british army's chemical
weapons unit as the west is warning of
the potential for biological and
chemical warfare in ukraine
and i'm going to be joined by a student
from glasgow going the extra mile by
driving an ambulance to the poland
ukrainian border to help refugees
fleeing the conflict
chelsea fans turned out in strength last
night supporting both the men's and
women's teams but the future of the club
is in question russian billionaire owner
roman abramovich has had his assets
frozen by the uk government in response
to the invasion of ukraine our sports
correspondent tom parmenter has been
taking a look
the abramovich era delivered every piece
of silverware to chelsea but the british
government say his close relationship
with vladimir putin means they've locked
down his uk assets
he'd already put chelsea up for sale but
the sanctions mean that if a new buyer
is found and approved abramovich won't
receive a penny
every employee has questions both the
men's and women's sides played and won
last night i know from my end
you know i'm a leader of this team and
we're going to have to navigate a
difficult period
and one where i don't have all the
answers for it
season ticket holders will still be able
to watch games but the club can't sell
any more tickets there'll be a transfer
ban and they're blocked from negotiating
new contracts
the club can't sell merchandise and
mobile phone firm three have already
suspended their sponsorship
and travel costs to away games will have
to be more modest longer trips abroad
might prove more difficult
fans at the women's match last night
were still taking it all in
we always support chelsea doesn't matter
what situation is going on so
nothing changes that
i've got you know
much more concerned for what's going on
in ukraine than
how he's feeling to be honest
at norwich city thomas tuchel's chelsea
side the current european champions were
also taking sanctuary in just playing
football there was a lot of distraction
another level of distraction actually
with the sanctions
and we could feel it that the players
talk about it that are aware of it and
we accepted it
playing and winning football matches is
something of a welcome distraction for
everyone connected to chelsea football
club right now the roman abramovich era
has ended in the most extraordinary way
his links to the kremlin overriding
everything
and still last night they chanted his
name
football does have a habit of turning a
blind eye if the money and goals are
flowing but in the space of just a few
weeks the world
has changed
tom parmenter sky news norwich
uh some other news for you now and as we
were just discussing with the minister
meta platforms are allowing facebook and
instagram users in some countries to
call for violence against russians and
russian soldiers of course in relation
to the invasion taking place in ukraine
the social media company is making
temporary changes to its hate speech
policy that will allow some posts that
call for the death of vladimir putin or
the belarusian president alexander
lukashenko
the un's nuclear watchdog says that
ukraine has lost all communications with
facilities at the chernobyl nuclear
plant it comes a day after the plant
lost all external power supplies
on the site of an enormous nuclear
accident in 1986
it's currently controlled by russian
forces
the russian defense ministry says it
will declare a ceasefire today and open
humanitarian corridors from five
ukrainian cities for fleeing citizens
all according to russian media it comes
after civilians were blocked from
leaving the port city of mario paul
yesterday after russian forces refused
to honor the ceasefire
now the government will ask people to
open their homes to ukrainians fleeing
the war amid continuing criticism of its
response so far to the refugee crisis
well a little earlier i spoke to the
technology minister chris philp about
what more the government was planning on
doing to help
we're going to be making announcements
in the very near future about a scheme
for uk local authorities and indeed uk
families
to welcome ukrainian refugees we've
announced that principle and the details
of how that scheme works will be laid
out in the very near future
would you take anyone in to your home i
mean do we know of anyone in the cabinet
that has already suggested that they
might be willing to open their doors
well i think once the details are
published in the very near future
everybody will have a look at that and
see if their personal circumstances
allow them to and you know i'm sure the
british public will look at that and if
they're able to some people will be able
to and some won't they'll they'll make
their own their own decisions
interesting initiative let's discuss
with our political correspondent
tomorrow cohen good to see you this
morning tc what do we make of this i
mean clearly some people are being
briefed about this being a plan the
minister this morning suggesting that we
might have to wait a little bit for
detail
that seems to be happening quite
regularly with this government so there
is going to be a new scheme announced on
monday a humanitarian scheme for
ukrainians who don't have a family
connection here in the uk those people
are allowed to come already this is for
people who would be sponsored by
organizations like local councils or
charities or churches who can put them
up somewhere but the reason that this
has been delayed is because a lot of
detail needs to be worked out and that's
being done by michael gove's leveling up
department as to exactly what they would
need to provide and how how long would
um some of these organizations need to
put up ukrainian refugees for and of
course part of this is going to be the
role of ordinary families who maybe have
a spare room and would like to offer it
up but of course wonderful as that
sounds um there's got to be some checks
and balances there it's been stressed to
me by people in government this morning
that not only
do you need to check ukrainians coming
into the uk but also you need to vet the
people who host them as well to make
sure that they are criminal records
checked and so exactly how this is going
to work and crucially what sort of
benefits um ukrainians coming to the uk
might be entitled to if they are treated
as refugees even if they are not coming
direct from ukraine they would be
entitled to
the right to work and all kinds of
benefits but they otherwise they may not
be entitled to all of it so all this is
being worked out at the moment as we
speak but we understand what the
government are looking at is a minimum
three or six months commitment for
someone offering to host one more to
discuss when we hear from uh thanks very
much
now western leaders are anticipating
that russia is planning to deploy
biological and chemical weapons in
ukraine as a means to accomplish their
objectives uh well let's speak now to
hey mr bretton garden former head of the
british army's chemical weapons unit
hamish always good to have you on the
channel um
before we delve into what is what may
well happen in ukraine for for those who
are not as of a with with the rules as
you what are the rules that govern
whether or not a country can use
chemical or biological weapons
well number one you can't chemical and
biological weapons have been uh illegal
really since the stop time of the geneva
convention was first conceived back in
the 1920s there are a number of other
conventions like the chemical weapons
convention signed in 1996 by
most countries around the world
including russia that outlaws the use of
chemical weapons biological weapons is a
slightly different area there is the
biological and toxin weapons convention
which outlaws them but the basic premise
these are absolutely horrendous weapons
indiscriminate mainly affects civilians
of course soldiers tend to have gas
masks and other protections so they are
illegal and horrendous under every law
that one can
conceive
what is their utility then for someone
like vladimir putin of course certainly
plenty of evidence that they have been
deployed
in his name before
what is their utility when it comes to a
combat the types of combat that we are
seeing in ukraine at the moment which is
an awful lot of street to street house
to house
well i tend to agree with a lot of other
commentators about what's been called
the russian playbook in syria i've seen
the russians have very close quarters
over the last six years uh in syria and
unfortunately chemical weapons are what
i've learned from my syrian experience
chemical weapons are morbidly brilliant
and you'd use them all the time if you
had no morals or scruples because
in
syria the towns and cities that were
attacked very similar to what we're
seeing um in ukraine with kiev and other
cities
once these cities are raised to the
ground the building's
fallen down it's almost impossible for
attackers to get a foothold and the
russians know all about this from
stalingrad in the second world war over
a million red army soldiers died
defending stalingrad but what happened
in syria is after the four-year
conventional battle for aleppo in
northwest syria
um
in december 2016 on 13 days a sad drop
chlorine barrel bombs and broke that
siege because the chlorine seeps
underground because it's heavier than
air and people hide in the rubble and
underground
and the chlorine either kills them
underground or forces some above ground
to be shot or captured and that also
worked for assad in a
suburb called ghouta and a suburb called
duma in 2017 in 2018. so they can be
very very successful and unfortunately
of course in august 2013 we had a
massive sarin attack
in damascus and the british government
voted in september 2013 not to punish
hassan and the americans followed soos
and i think that is really underwriting
why we are here now because that failure
to punish assad gave a green light to
every dictator despot rogue state and
terror group to use them and i think
putin thinks he can use them with
impunity yeah difficult to disagree with
that part of your analysis analysis so
what then should we be doing what then
can we do if anything is it just a case
of
waiting for the inevitable to happen and
preparing the case for the icc
well it's it's really difficult and uh i
know that people are terribly concerned
about us and nato getting over committed
in ukraine however again i point out the
syrian
experience
when we eventually attacked assad's key
sites
after the uh nerve agent attack in a
place called khan shakun in april 2017
and then we attacked again in 2018
uh his sights the chemical weapon
stopped asap knew if he used them he was
going to get thumped
we must
ensure that putin understands the
consequences
of his actions and perhaps enable even
more the ukrainian air force and
military to be able to attack some of
his strategic bits of equipment and
strategic sites with more equipment and
i personally think
we should be giving ukrainian army more
more aircraft so that they can um win
the battle in the
hey mr bretton gordon great to have you
on the show this morning thanks for
joining us
well there are reports this morning that
russian forces are moving closer to
ukraine's capital kiev doctors and
nurses in and around the capital are now
running a frontline medical facility
given over entirely to treating wounded
ukrainian soldiers our special
correspondent alex crawford reports now
from the edge of kiev
they arrive stuffed into car boots
and on the back seats they're taking
some terrible hits trying to stop the
russian troops entering the ukrainian
capital
laid out on already blood-soaked
stretchers
the soldiers have just been shelled on a
front line which is creeping ever closer
to key
and it's the nearest hospital now
entirely turned over to dealing with the
war wounded
these aren't army medics they're the
towns doctors and nurses who two weeks
ago were dealing with births and bone
breaks
now they plunged into a new world spent
trying to save the lives of soldiers and
civilians torn apart by bombs and
bullets
it's the worldversary
it's world war three it's very versatile
and it could be stopped here or it could
move through the whole world through all
the doors please help us to stop this
world
they are shell-shocked and shaking
and so far the politicians peace talks
have got nowhere
hospitals are protected locations under
international law but no one here trusts
that to be observed
yet there's an astonishing resilience
and perhaps a realization they have no
option
it's not difficult for us to fight he
tells us we're defending our land and
we'll continue to protect it
but then he delivers a rousing call not
just to his fellow ukrainian men and
women but also the rest of the world
everyone has to stand together he says
glory to ukraine our army will win
this is on the northwest edge of the
capital and we found multiple vehicles
and homes which had been hit apparently
indiscriminately
there seems to be no shortage of lucky
escapes he was on duty as an emergency
worker
his house five houses from here
there are thousands of lives abruptly
halted by this war
pets abandoned in the rush to keep out
of the way of the rockets and bombs
families who've upped and left
everything just to try to survive
there's a constant sound of artillery
and shelling going on and you can see
the devastation that some of the attacks
have already had
we know
according to the locals here that the
russians are only a few kilometers down
the road and this
is the constant backdrop
so those who can't or won't leave live
in a shadowy underground world below the
booming war sounds
about half of the capital's population
has fled the city according to the mayor
it smells
these are the bravest of women tending
to some of the community's most
vulnerable and most frightened
we've already learned how to tell the
difference between our side shooting and
the enemies natalia tells us we can
identify everything and we're just
trying to keep everyone calm
they're already living under siege here
with sons and partners fighting and
their homes bombed
it says
for sure this is a crime and putin has
to be punished she tells us
they're engaged in the fight of their
lives to stop the russian troops
advancing any further
but their president's warning much more
of their blood will be spilt unless his
nation gets international military
support
alex crawford sky news on the edge of
the capital kyiv
well the war in ukraine has created the
biggest refugee crisis since the second
world war my next guest
well he's planning on heading to the
ukraine poland border in an ambulance
that he and his family have bought to
help those injured as they flee the war
zone i'm very pleased to say that umran
ali javid johns is now on the program
omran great to see you this morning as i
understand it you know you're a student
at glasgow caledonian university
good to see you as well yeah i'm a
student studying international tourism
and event management at glasgow
california university
goodwin university that we've got my
little brother went there and it's also
producing someone like you so to tell us
the thought behind all of this buying an
ambulance and driving up all the way to
the ukrainian border what prompted this
well it's heartbreaking to see the
energies and videos that are coming out
of ukraine
so i wanted to do something to help them
and i know that these ambulances they've
got distinct markings and you know and a
distinct color so they can help evacuate
innocent civilians and people with
disabilities through evacuation routes
and hopefully
that's what it's going to do because
it's going to be handed over to a
ukrainian charity to
do that
so when are you sent when are you
setting off imran i mean it's it's not
an easy drive at the best of times but
given that you know the place that
you're heading to is essentially on the
edge of a war zone might make it even
more problematic a journey
yeah yeah
basically i've got a class um at
university at 2 p.m and i finish at 4 pm
after class i'm going straight to the
border and to england getting a ferry to
the netherlands then into germany and
then into poland and then other
ukrainian border is where they're
meeting me and the charity to take
responsibility of the ambulance so it's
not really a big deal to be honest i've
done it many times i've took many
ambulances before so i should be there
by monday
yes tell us tell us
just a little bit about that i noticed
that this is not the first time that
you've done this you've taken ambulances
to burma syria iraq yemen places like
that this has been something you've been
doing for quite some time
yeah yeah i've been doing it for a few
years now and the first time
i went to the gaza strip with medical
supplies and i've seen a couple of
ambulances get through so i thought this
is like a really great idea to get and
to take ambulances where they're needed
and secondhand british ambulances are
really really and good that way to help
patients
and get to the hospitals or where
they're needed at medical center
and it's just like heartbreaking to see
whenever i go to burma or
these places it's heartbreaking just to
see what's going on there
we're just looking at pictures of a very
apparently very peaceful and tranquil
key every wonder how how long that will
last for but just just tell us
how have you paid for this because the
last time i well
my days as a student are very much in
the dim
the dim and distant past but i certainly
didn't have two and a half grand sitting
in my bank account to go off and buy an
ambulance
yeah yeah so um
two days ago um i went to
the there's a retail shop here that
takes second-hand equipment so i sold
one on my graphics card and i got 775
pounds for that it's like they're not in
demand they're in demand these days and
that will pay for my fuel costs and
stuff and i had some savings left over i
do like to save my money but um you know
just seeing what's going on
i'm just trying to help in any way i can
and i think everyone's trying to do that
help like there's a lot of people in the
community
that are trying to help in their own way
by donating money i could like i'm able
to donate an ambulance and i know that
it could make a difference maybe
them to a few hundred people but like
it's not much of a difference because
tens of thousands of people need help
but at least it'll make some difference
well done mate very good very good on
you drive safely and i hope you make it
back in time i'm told you've got classes
on tuesday you've got to be back for
yeah yeah so i hopefully i'll be back on
tuesday to be back in time for my class
and if i'm late the university hopefully
will be easy on me
i'm just going to say if you need if you
need someone to write a letter and run
i'm i'm willing i'm putting my name
forward just give me a shout
drive safely and uh well look we'll
we'll maybe speak to you when you get
back uh um ali
welcome back just a little bit of
breaking news uh to bring you the
russian steelmaker evraz has said that
10 members of its board have quit
following the british sanction of their
largest shareholder roman abramovich and
the suspension of its shares only the
chief executive of everest remains on
its board we'll have a look at that and
bring you more on that as and when we
get it about uk families well as we've
been reporting they will be asked to
open their homes to ukrainian refugees
with the government set to outline next
week a sponsored humanitarian route
comes after the government has faced
growing criticism over their visa scheme
for people fleeing ukraine one person
knows a thing or two about the struggles
of bypassing the visa restrictions at
tanya birch joins us on the program
tanya lovely to see you this morning and
and just to kind of give our give our
viewers just a little bit of context
you're ukrainian yourself you've been
living here for 25 years
but your family of course have had some
issues just tell us about those
well i um came to uk 25 years ago and
i'm you know ukrainian and i'm a british
citizen as well when the war broke out
well before the war broke out i was
begging my entire family to just go at
least to poland they refused they were
withdrawing cash they were planning to
stay and support the refugees
so when the bro when the war broke out
my
system i think it was on the tenth day
and her grandchildren they decided to
be you know to allow themselves to be
evacuated to poland
it took them 24 hours from leave to to
reach broadslope which they could have
been really in australia by then um
tremendously difficult time crossing the
border standing in the freezing you know
well
in very cold weathers in at night
traveling 24 hours so when they reached
roslove um
i was delighted
and booked uh flight to broadslove
in hope that once we have applied for
ukrainian family scheme um i will be
able to go and collect them
um because they are in charge she's my
sister she's entitled to come to the
united kingdom we've got accommodation
we've got you know finances we've got so
many friends and family
waiting to love on her and her grandkids
however when i flew in
um
i just kept going on the website that
was provided and i could not um secure
an appointment for their biometrics
i'm so sorry to interrupt we're really
pushed for time what what is the current
status then what is our current visa
status
um she's still waiting i flew back from
poland unfortunately without her and the
kids yesterday and she's still waiting
for the visa
oh dear and how how are you and
and how is she doing
oh well she's helped she's happy she's
in safety however it was just
heartbreaking to you know hug her
goodbye and the kids and you know they
were clinging
because they are just hanging in the
limbo they don't know how long it's
going to take for them to get this visa
um
what hope do you have that that your
family might be joining you in the
united kingdom anytime soon
um it is um you know good to know that
they don't have to wait for you know
days weeks or months for this biometrics
appointment however we don't know when
the visa is going to be issued
we still don't know any dates and the
helplines
um couldn't give me any times
of when the visa would be issued so even
though it is slightly better news it's
still challenging we're just literally
waiting for this visa to arrive tatiana
we will keep our fingers crossed that
you your sister the rest of your family
will be reunited very very soon we'll
keep in touch and hopefully speak again
for now though thanks very much
thank you